welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Benjamin Dixon let's take a look at
the story of Donald Trump in his
deranged attempt to do anything he can
to possibly stop this immigration crisis
that doesn't really exist we'll talk
about that more in a minute but Yahoo
News and several other outlets are
reporting that the that the Trump
administration wants to hold migrant
children indefinitely from Yahoo News
quote the Trump administration said on
Thursday it plans to withdraw from a
federal court agreement that strictly
limits the conditions under which
authorities can detain migrant children
and proposed new rules it said would
enable it to detain minors during their
immigration proceedings the
administration has long targeted the
Flores settlement agreement in 1997
federal consent decree the decree rather
that places significant curbs on how
long and in what conditions the
government can detain migrant children
as it seeks to dissuade migrants from
crossing the u.s. southern border now
again like this that last quote just
said this is 100% about instilling fear
into potential migrants from coming and
not only just migrants immigrants but
also asylum seekers and what the
administration understands but doesn't
care is that in many times asylum
seekers and people who are seeking to
just simply come to America to better
their conditions have already made the
conscious decision that whatever happens
to them in America is better than their
what they're going through in their home
country that's already a part of the
calculus so what Donald Trump is
attempting to do is not going to be a
deterrent but it really is nothing more
than playing to these racist
sensibilities of his base and I say that
also because there literally is no
crisis at the border if you look at the
actual data the nation com actually did
some amazing reporting on this and as
well as the Washington Post if you look
at the actual data immigration our
illegal immigration at the border has
decreased significantly the decrease has
been a constant decline over the last
decade it did not increase simply
because of Donald Trump it the trend
began before President Obama and so
there is no
order crisis yet they continuously
create this boogeyman that pushes their
voters to the pole and keeps them
constantly enraged that's what this is
about this is about making sure that
they make a statement to their
supporters as well as to the rest of the
world that they want America to maintain
its whiteness they literally like I
there's a clip of and I may get this
clip put in here of Bill O'Reilly
talking to then candidate for president
senator not Lindsey Graham but the one
that just died John McCain John McCain
he's having a conversation with John
McCain back in 2008 and he literally
described this situation as the Browning
of America that is exactly what they're
trying to avoid and this is why they're
playing to this problem that doesn't
exist but I want to read a little bit
more from Yahoo News this is what they
said quote the regulation released on
Thursday if it goes into effect would
enshrine some of the protections while
circumventing others by allowing the
government to detain children in
facilities not licensed by state
authorities to hold minors Trump
administration officials have repeatedly
referred to the agreement agreement
standards as loopholes that attract
migrants by forcing authorities to
release people pending their immigration
hearings catch and release is what they
use is a way of making this propaganda
talking about propagandistic talking
point basically this is the catch and
release and so they feel as though this
is something that's going to deter
illegal immigration or even asylum
seekers when in reality people have
already made that calculus they know
Donald Trump is in the White House they
know what's going to happen to them when
they get to America and they're leaving
conditions that are so or that are so
terrifying that they're willing to face
this and this is why this rule is has
nothing really
Donald Trump is aware of that first of
all let me before I finish their
sentence the Trump administration and
all of the people involved in this
Stephen Miller Allen are fully aware of
this condition that people are the
conditions that people are fleeing and
they know that people are still going to
come they also know that there is
actually no
order crisis so all of this is a part of
a calculated effort to do nothing but
continuously stoke anger amongst their
supporters I want to read a quote from
Omar ja droite he's a director of the
ACL u--'s immigrants rights / project
and this is what he had to say very
simply he said it is sickening to see
the United States government looking for
ways to jail more children for longer
periods of time and this is this is
absolutely the case they have no regard
for human life or human decency or
dignity they are looking for they're
actually getting enjoyment they are
seeking for the opportunity to do more
damage this is the caliber of people we
are dealing with and I think we have to
make sure that we're clear we have a
clear-eyed view of what these people
want to do because I think sometimes we
like to err on the side of giving people
the benefit of the doubt or we make the
naive mistake of arguing within the
framework that they give us they want to
give us a framework of immigration as a
problem our illegal immigration is a
problem in reality illegal immigration
has been dramatically increased even
during the Obama administration so you
know it's not a problem and in actuality
if we completely shatter the frame that
they try to give us we have to
understand in full context that this is
about them playing to the fears of white
genocide literally in fact
I mentioned it before but we're gonna
put it here play this clip of Bill
O'Reilly letting them know that this is
about the Browning of America and about
preserving the white male Christian
power structure change pardon the pun
the whole complexion of America am I
wrong no you're right the second thing
that the on the Left they're against is
is the temporary worker as you know we
say two years go back for a year two
years go back for a year they don't want
that they don't want them to have to go
back what the strategy is well can come
and work do you understand and I'm not
saying this in the condescending way
you're smarter than I am but do you
understand what the New York Times wants
and the far left want they want to break
down the white
Christian male power structure of which
you are a part and so am I and they want
to bring in millions of foreign
nationals to basically break down the
structure that we have I mean he clearly
said it that those are their words and
that's all the way back in 2008 and
that's when we consider America to have
been a more civilized time this is pre
Donald Trump madness and now we're in a
play in a world where the steve banners
of the world well he's gone but he was
there and the stephen miller's who was
still there and people who are connected
to white nationalists are still
connected to Donald Trump and Donald
Trump has allegedly said that his
biggest mistake was condemning the Nazis
in charlottesville look at where we are
now and compare it to where they were in
2008 and you see a direct line through
this thinking the immigration is going
to cause the Browning of America and
send us into a place where the white
male Christian power structure is
destroyed that is their number one
concern and that is what this is all
about and they are willing to sacrifice
all of these children simply to carry
out their fight against immigration one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high quality
classes on almost any topic the first
500 people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on how
to become a more productive person I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or will
help you with something in your everyday
life classes are taught by real people
who care about what they're teaching I
just took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video I mean really just think
about everything that you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free that's hard to beat and
after
that if you like it you can keep having
access to every class on Skillshare for
less than 10 bucks a month it's one of
the most affordable learning platforms
out there just click the link under this
video to redeem your to three months of
skill share but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up